because I just kept watching Pokemon
even after everyone had like even when
the crazy awesome and my mom was my mom
without wondering like why is this kid
still into Pokemon [ __ ] is going on I
had the same thing my parents were like
they were like worried for me they were
like should we like doing these like do
something about this like he's still
like watching cartoons and my older
brother had like full gone cartoons yeah
there's a sign of pride but he stopped
watching games like I only watched
reality TV show now with my parents I
don't watch this kids i watch game TV
yeah right right
yeah yeah and I [ __ ] loved light you
know Samurai Jack like I would always
try and watch Samurai Jack like scars
Cowardly Dog anime as well my parents
genuinely like what concern for me I
don't know if they still are concerns
act point cuz all the way up to
university and when I've rediscovered
what anime was my parents like he's
doing it again will pass this [ __ ]
phase when they found out I was watching
like more anime than ever they were more
concerned they were like woah he's gone
even harder into you I thought it would
stop I remember my dad like the funniest
thing my dad ever said I think I was in
like late maybe the last year of high
school
yeah and that was like when I was like
hot this right before I made my youtube
channel
I know was like watching every anime
ever my dad would be like what are you
doing in your room because he thought I
was doing something else
yeah and when I told him that I was
watching anime I remember my dad saying
like okay at this point I think I'd
rather you just do drugs I would have
been less disappointed if I found that
you were doing drugs which ones more
life crushing yeah but like I don't know
like I guess like I don't really have
like a phase of like when I described in
anime or anything because as long as
I've known why do yeah that's like even
manga as well like I started reading
manga like around the same time that I
discovered or I'm won't we just probably
around when I was like four or five
years old
howtechs you've been reading manga since
four or five probably maybe earlier than
that but I'd specifically remember the
first ever volume of manga ever got was
volume 2 of Doraemon I don't know why my
mom didn't get me volume 1 would be cool
but like I didn't know that it was like
her Hawking story so I was like okay
I'll just start reading this I had no
idea what the [ __ ] was going on at first
until I call volume 1 and I'll say odd
now it makes it's like a WoW